c'est un bon mois il a toutes les
qualités requises de la télévision
télévisuellement parlant il a le
physique
il a les lunettes il a le la le manteau
et il a tout ce qu'il faut et
franchement ça fait du bien enfin
d'avoir quelqu'un qui n'est pas langue
de bois mais jusqu'au bout et qui assume
totalement ses prises de position et il
est calé sur son sujet et comme l'a dit
raymond quand il a une personne en face
une personne qui est censé être mieux
qualifié que lui de haut niveau des
connaissances et il sait mieux que tout
le monde et il le prend il le prouve
donc je trouve ça génial la lie à la cdu
bon vous allez avoir qu'il verdez après
de son humour et sa répartie l'a prouvé
que toutes les personnes qui ont une
pensée à l'encontre de celle qui est
véhiculée par le gouvernement ne sont
pas que des fous et que des complotistes
mais aussi des armes qu'ils
réfléchissent et qu'ils nous font
réfléchir je trouve qui nous a fait
beaucoup réfléchir nous a posé des
questions il nous a éclairés sur le
colis donc bravo fabrice il a fait du
bien au fait plaisir face et
philosophiques
oui oui forcément après ça aurait
opposerais je vous dire que je m'en fous
un peu ouais c'est pas dur batteur
doublé danger public sur ce plateau des
dossiers feront répondent aux autres
mais bon en fait c'est marrant je prends
je savais que j'allais dire ça et donc
du coup ça m'a permis je triche un peu
préparé ma réplique est en réalité je
savais que vous alliez dire que j'étais
dangereux
c'est pourquoi je le savais parce que
tout le monde l'a dit si je fais
réfléchir et je comprends que quelqu'un
comme dit quelqu'un qui fasse réfléchir
ça paraisse dangereux en fait parce que
vous êtes tellement insignifiant mais je
le dis très calmement et avec beaucoup
beaucoup de respect beaucoup
effectivement de ce film et tranquillité
c'est souleymane jamais on sait jamais
avec vous quelle est la part de vérité
qu'est la part de chine